ROBERT ROBBINS: Why
should we care about what
this mission is all about?
DANTE LAURETTA: We're going
back 4 and 1/2 billion years
to the dawn of the solar
system to understand
why Earth is a habitable planet,
why there are oceans here,
and how did the seeds of life
get to the surface of the Earth
to trigger the origin and
evolution to humans today?
But we also look forward.
Our tag line is "exploring our
past and securing our future."
Asteroid impacts are one of
the greatest natural disasters
facing humanity.
And we're developing
the technologies
to get out there, characterize
a potential impactor,
and if we need to, deflect that
asteroid away from an impact
with the planet.
One are the
other side benefits
is economic development for
not only Tucson but Southern
Arizona, the state, the region,
and in fact, the country.
Yeah.
OSIRIS-REx has had a
huge economic impact
on the city of Tucson
and the state of Arizona.
Over $200 million
in contract work
came directly to the U of A
as a result of this mission.
Obviously, that's good
for the institution
because that feeds forward into
all kinds of infrastructure
and support.
But to me, most importantly,
it attracts top talent
to the University of Arizona.
We have the best
engineers and scientists
in the world working
on this program right
here in our hometown.
Not only that, we're training
our University of Arizona
students using that expertise.
They get to do real
science, real engineering,
get those resumes
absolutely outstanding,
and then go off into the world
and make an economic impact
of their own.
And so Dani, you're an alum.
You were one of
Dante's students,
and now, you're one of the
leaders of this mission
on the scientific side.
There are unparalleled
opportunities
for the students that
attend this school.
We have been very fortunate.
We've trained a number
of undergraduate students
just in the working
group that I lead.
But there have
been students that
have worked in our
engineering disciplines,
helping with the operations,
commanding the instruments
for OSIRIS-REx.
And so this project has really
been an incredible impetus
for training the
next generation.
Both of you are actually alums
of the University of Arizona.
Tell me more about your
story about why did you
choose the University of
Arizona in the first place?
And how did you go from being a
bright-eyed, first-year student
to where you are now?
I originally came to
the University of Arizona
because it's renowned for
its astronomy department.
My mom is an alumni of
the University of Arizona.
And so, yeah, I remember
actually going to the Flandrau
Planetarium as part
of Girl Scout camp
in elementary school
Yeah, so I have
a long memory of
associating U of A
with exploring the universe.
I actually took a class with
Dante my first semester,
as a freshman.
And at the end of
that semester, I
sent him an email because I
thought the class was great.
It was a class on
meteorites and how
they link back to asteroids.
And said I really
enjoyed the class.
If there's any
opportunities that you
might have in your lab, I'd
love to hear about them.
And we've been working
together for a long time.
That was over a decade ago.
I can't imagine
another place where
you could come as
an undergraduate
and be part of a NASA mission.
And this is the
second NASA mission
that the University
of Arizona has led,
and that's unprecedented.
NASA just doesn't let
universities do that.